après
regardez en juin dernier la France a été
secouée par une vague d'émeutes après la
mort du jeune Naël tué par le tir d'un
policier et alors qu'une cagnotte avait
été créée pour soutenir la famille de
l'adolescent Jean Messia avait décidé
d'en fonder une autre qui a récolté 1,6
million d'euros j'ai pris l'initiative
de lancer une cagnotte pour la famille
du policier surnommé la cagnotte de la
honte elle avait rapidement suscité
l'indignation de certaines personnes et
c'est une provocation c'est scandaleux
et après une plainte déposée par la
famille de Naël contre Jean Messia pour
escroqu en bande organisée l'homme a été
convoqué aujourd'hui par la police alors
Jean Messie a entendu pour escroquerie
après la cagnotte pour la famille du
policier auteur du tir mortel sur Naël
êtes-vous choqué par cette cagnotte on n
pas choqué non merci Jean Messia d'être
avec nous qui est choqué par cette
cagnotte oui non non non oui oui non oui
non oUI NON NON oui Jean Messia vous
êtes président du cercle de réflexion
vive français tout à fait s de
réflexion euh est-ce que on va revenir
sur ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui parce
que je sais que tout le monde voulait
que vous venz tout le monde vous invité
ce soir merci je le sais je le sais
merci vous êtes des amours non mais non
mais non mais pas
[Rires]
nous tout le monde vous
voulez de votre vous avezend aujourd'hui
des centaines de potes ça fait chaud au
cœur non vousê vous êtes vousê vous avez
été entendu aujourd'hui j'étaé entendu
ouais par la police oui alors il va
prendre 20 piges pas du tout attendez on
va en parler dans un instant est-ce que
tu as bien mangé en prison tu as maigri
j'ai
maigriel tu vas parvenir
la vérité la vérité c'est lui qui sort
d'auto là avec sa barbe ça y est alors
lui aussi
tu sérieux on va pas les vannes là c'est
bon plus les vannes elles sont pas ouf
les gars vous comprenez cette plainte
contre votre cagnotte ou pas ben en fait
je l'ai jamais comprise et je l'ai
encore moins comprise aujourd'hui
puisque l'avantage quand vous vous
rendez à une audition libre c'est que on
vous
montre le contenu des plaintes qui sont
déposées contre vous et notamment les
éléments mat ériel qui viennent fonder
ces plaintes F or les dossiers sont
vides c'est exactement comme si je
disais à Bernard Montiel qu'il avait tué
son voisin et que le parquet convoquait
Bernard Montiel juste sur mes
déclarations parce que j'ai dit qu'il
avait tué son voisin donc moi j'ai pris
j'ai eu les dossiers entre les mains là
ce soir Bern Monti n'a jamais tué
personne voilà mais mais c'est pareil
mais c'est comme moi moi je n'ai jamais
escroqué personne c'est c'est c'est
votre conclusion est la bonne donc moi
quand j'ai vu si vous voulez qu'il n'y
avait rien que c'était que du déclaratif
vous a dit quoi aujourd'hui ils vous ont
dit quoi alors bah il vous arrivez vous
arrivez donc là vous êtes entendu par
combien de je suis entendu par par un
policier ouais un policier j'étais avec
mes deux avocats donc maître Frédéric
Pichon et maître Gérald
pendelon euh et donc ça a duré 2h et3i à
peu près ouais et j'ai répondu à toutes
les questions qui cé quoi les questions
c'éta quoi bah les questions c'est voilà
quand est-ce pourquoi vous avez monté
cette cagnotte est-ce que vous avez été
en contact au préalable avec la famille
du policier ou avec ses collègues
voilà c'est c'est des des questions qui
visent à à éclairer en fait pour vous
avez monté cette cagnotte bah parce
qu'en fait j'ai trouvé ça absolument un
vraisemblable que un policier qui est
impliqué dans une affaire dont personne
au moment où on en parlait à l'époque
était connaissait les tenants et les
aboutissants on jette en quelque sorte
l'alali sur ce policier puisque quand au
plus haut niveau de l'État Emmanuel
Macron quelques heures à peine après cet
événement dit que le geste du policier
est inexcusable au mépris de
l'indépendance des pouvoirs parce que
c'est pas un président de la République
dans une démocratie moderne de juger si
un geste est inexcusable ou pas ça c'est
le pouvoir judiciaire qui doit qui doit
en juger donc j'ai pas compris pourquoi
tout le système médiatico-politique se
jetait je faisais un Arau sur le
policier sans considération pour sa
présomption d'innocence sans
considération pour la famille qu'il y a
derrière je rappelle quand même que ce
policier a été une fois qu'il a été en
prison préventive a été empêché pendant
un mois et demi de de d'avoir la visite
de sa femme et de son enfant en basâge
ce qui est du jamais vu dans une telle
affaire même les membres du Grand
bandettisme en 48 he ils ont ils peuvent
voir leur famille au parloir là non
alors Gilles Verdez vous euh on va on va
parler donc avec jeanb vous vous êtes
vous trouvez êtes choqué par cette
cagnotte mais juste alors donc qu'est-ce
qu'ils vous ont dit au bout de 2h de bah
au bout de 2h de forcé de constater que
il n'y a rien dans le dossier puisque la
vérité c'est que on na jamais vu
d'escroqueries sans escroc et d'escroc
sans escroquerie si vous voulez j'ai
excroqué personne la bande organisée B
ils ne l'ont pas démontré alors pire ils
m'ont dit enfin l'accusation de de
l'avocat de la famille c'est que
j'aurais utilisé des données de fichiers
confidentiels auquel j'aurais eu accès
de manière
illégale sauf que l'enquête faite par
les policiers montre que toutes les
informations que j'ai diffusé sur mes
réseaux sociaux en réalité elles étaient
elles étaient déjà disponibles plusieurs
heures sinon plusieurs jours avant on
est làsier donc donc en fait ça tombe
voilà il y a pas de y a pas
d'utilisation mais peu importe qu'elle
soit disponible peu importe qu'elle soit
disponible bah si non laisse parler les
grand non mais
pourcqu d'abord pourquoi pourquoi c'est
non mais je connais l'argument
l'argument il nous l'a déjà sorti
l'année dernière selon lequel la semaine
dernière pardon selon lequel toutes les
le fait que les informations ne soient
pas publiques sousentendrait que vous
étiez de mèche et que vous c'est ça le
problème et et c'est bien ce que
j'allais dire c'est que toutes les
informations étaient déjà publi donc il
y a rien il y a rien à démontrer dans
cette affaire mais moi pour répondre
directement à cette question non je suis
pas choqué je suis pas choqué parce que
il s'agit de deux choses différent c'est
pas la peine il y a il y a il y a une
procédure judiciaire qui est en cours
c'est très rare de voir un policier dans
un cas comme celui-là être mis en
préventif pendant 4 mois et demi et de
toute façon cette cagnotte et il y a une
cagnotte qui est lancée vous l'avez
lancé pour le policier
est la
fam non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est totalement décorré de l'action
judiciire donc je ne vois pas en quoi ce
serait choquant la seule chose c'est que
personne n'est DUP du fait que vous
l'avez fait aussi pour des raisons je
dirais politiques et bien s
queend juste
làdessus la récupération politique
ouinrument tion politique c'est on
récupère quelque chose qui existe déjà
là je n'ai rien récupéré puisque rien
n'existait en fait ce sont les 85000
donateurs qui on ont fait un élément
politique vous comprenez que la CAG
attendez si la cagnotte avait plafonné à
2 ou 3000 € est-ce qu'on aurait fait cet
émission ce soir est-ce qu'il y aurait
tous ces problèmes non estce qu'il
faut si vous êtes poursuivi c'est aussi
parce qu'il y a quelque chose d'ammoral
de le faire au moment où vous l'avez
faitors vous êtes en train de me dire
que dans une démocratie moderne quand on
est choqué par quelque chose on peut
finir en prison
moi moi je vous dis d'abord que je ne
suis pas choqué par cette cette
cagot j'essaie d'interpréter le le le la
réaction et je pense que la famille de
du jeune Naël et tous ceux qui sont
entre guillemets face à vous vous
reprochent une faute morale une faute
politique d'avoir essayer
d'instrumentaliser cet événement de
voilà ça je ça je comprends tout à fait
je comprends tout à fait ça moi-même je
suis choqué par plein d'autres choses en
face mais être choqué par quelque chose
ne sign pas que c'est quelque chose de
criminalisable de
criminalis TR TR je pas les traduire en
justice et j'allais vous dire que ce
weekend la manifestation où il y avait
que 500 personnes à nanter en soutien à
la famille de naë c'est la même chose
aussi c'est une action politique voilà
oui monsieur oui vous êtes moi je suis g
intervenir parce que Jean M déroule son
tapis rouge après son audition mais
c'est scandaleux son argumentaire je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi il dit les
données étaient publiques d'accord on
lui reproche d'avoir fait passer naë
pour un multirécidiviste en prenant des
informations confidentielles et en les
diffusant et jean- Messie a dit les
informations étaient publiques mais
Cyril on s'en fout totalement que ce
soit privé ou publique si c'est public
et qu'il utilise ces informations ça
s'appelle du recel et d'ailleurs bah si
c'est du RESSEL bah évidemment j'an mais
pas du tout vous avez été entendu pour
ça vous m'avez attend entend je peux
vous répondre à cet élément à peine de
commencer mais si vous voulez répondez
point par point point par point vous me
reprochez ça vous l'avez vous l'avez dit
vous l'avez dit la dernière fois vous je
peux répondre ou pas rel répond jeiss
répondre je vous dis simplement que que
cet argument à la noix vous l'avez déjà
utilisé la dernière fois qui est
complètement fallacieux la première
chose AZ dit au policiers de la brigade
financière que c'était à la noix un
argument à no oui oui parce que c'est
pas c'est pas les policiers qui disent
ça c'est c'est la partie adverse qui dit
ça et la partie adverse elle ne dit que
des
sont pas PRV d'cord
desair la
cagot je pas autorisé à meoyer so
d'accord on y vient alors l' comment
soleim la cagnotte lorsqu'elle a été
lancée la cagnotte lorsqu'elle a été
lancée prononcer on ne fait pas on ne
fait pas référence dans la cagnotte à
naë la cagnotte n'a pas été fait contre
na contre contre sa famille la cagnotte
a été lancée pour soutenir la famille du
policier il y a pas de mention à Naël ou
à sa famille dans la cagnotte donc tout
ça c'est du n'importe quoi vous mélangez
des choses qui ne sont pas mélangeables
le parcours comment dirais-je de petit
voyou qui était celui de Naël avant sa
fin tragique ça n'a rien à voir avec la
lati au donateur jeania vous avez menti
au donateurs c'est ça qu'on vous
reproche pourquoi les donateurs pas là
vous par mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a Daniel
pourquoi les
dons il
RA pourquoi les donateurs n'ont pas
porté plainte la question répond à cette
question quelqu'un si j'ai menti à
quelqu'un pourquoi il a pas porté
plainte contre moi si s'est senti
escroquer les donateurs ils ont pas
donné procuration à à la famille de Na
pour porter plainte contre moi vous
vivez dans quel état alors oui mamie non
j'ai juste dit pourquoi menti
par excuse-moi c'était très factuel il
était connu pour 15 fait il avait pas
été mis jamais mis en examen mais voilà
donc il il a jamais connu pour fait de
quoi il a piqué les données du
traitement des antécédents j dis
à ah jearrange oui oui oui fa n'importe
quoi
faire
vous avez utilisé les
donnation c'est pas moi qui vais payer
le frais
d'avoc je te dis tu démeras tout seul
qu'est-ce qui a dit mais c'est vrai vous
êtes merveilleux et bravo pour tout bra
bra pour
ili j'ai menti ou en quoi j'ai menti
toujours pas dit oui
pardonz expliqué au donateurs que naë
était un autre garçon que ce qu'il était
en réalité les les les donateurs onont
pas eu besoin de moi en l'occurrence
pour se faire une idée du pédigré de
Naël arrête de dire des bêtises mais
c'est vous qui avez lancé la cagnotte
une première plateforme l'a refusé la
deuxème l'AC la cagnotte est venue
quelques jours après la mort de naë les
gens étaient déjà archi au courant de
qui il était arrêtez avec ça Messia il y
a pas mal de gens qui réagissent qui
disent que vous avez été euh vous dites
avoir été auditionné en édition libre et
vous dites que votre avocat l'avocat de
la partie adverse était présent non non
son avocat non non avocat ord très bien
ouais et pas pas donc vous étiez en
audition voilà bah oui parce qu'il y a
en fait dans le dossier il y a rien qui
permette de détaer quoi que ce so ça va
être entendu à nouveau ou bien fini
terminé non je pense que ça je je peux
pas préjuger de ce qui va advevenir mais
enfin en tout cas le dossier est
totalement vide c'est un procès
politique c'est pas un procès juridique
puisqu'il n'y a aucun élément de fait ou
de droit susceptible de justifier une
poursuite de la procédure depuis le
début d'ailleurs si le parquet a ouvert
une enqu a accepté en 48 heur d'ouvrir
cette enquête c'est tout simplement pour
des raisons politiques pour calmer les
émeutes qui est au demorant même est un
échec puisque les émeutes ont quand même
lie mais vous êtes conscient que c'était
peut-être pas très àroit de le faire au
moment où vous l'avez fait c'était quand
même c'est surtout ça quand je parlais
tout à l'heure de faute morale c'est
quand même quelque chose qui était très
choquant à ce momentl on était tous un
peu sous le choc quand même morale c'est
une faute morale de soutenir la famille
d'un
policierz moi j'avais une question
généralement quand il y a une famille
qui est endeuillée qui qui s qui a perdu
quelqu'un là on crée une cagnotte ça je
suis d'accord moi ma question elle est
factuelle elle est simple elle est
innocente c'est que je ne comprends pas
pourquoi on crée une cagnotte pour ce
monsieur là je parle pas des faits je
parle pas des faits même pour sa famille
Mme pour sa
FAM je comprends pourquoi on crée une
cagnotte quand c'est pour payer les
faavocat et ca mais pourquoi jus 1
millionondre SAV pas il SAV pas que ça
pr tu la coupe la cagnotte ça se coupe
une cagnotte je vais vous
répondreli je vais je vais vous répond
dans la tête des gens ça sonne comme une
récompense quand même et c'est un peu
délicat oui je vous entends mais je vais
vous répondre lorsque le policier
lorsque lorsque le policier a été
lorsque le policier a été immédiatement
embastillé en en prison préventive et
que l'adresse de sa femme et de son
petit enfant ont été dénoncé sur les
réseaux sociaux une première fois puis
une deuxième le traitement c'estàdire le
salaire du policier a été interrompu
donc on a derrière cette affaire une
famille qui était aussi dans la
tourmente et je vois pas au nom de quoi
on serait interdit de ne pas avoir de
compassion pour la famille d'un policier
et au nom de quoi notre seule compassion
doit aller vers la famille vers la
famille d'un petit voyou excusez-mo
est-ce que la question que tout le monde
se pose est-ce que c'était pour créer un
buzz aussi cette CAN c'était pas pour
créer un buzz attendez mais encore une
fois est-ce que moi je suis maître de ce
que de de de de ce que de de ce que la
cagnotte est devenue si la cagnotte
avait avait avait plafonné à 1000 ou
2000 € C
personne n'en aurait parlé c'est pas moi
oui c'est pas moi qui c'est pas moi moi
j'ai lancé un appel mais on aurait pu
avoir 2 10000 7000 8000 je sais pas qui
aurait imaginé qu'on aurait près de
100000 donateurs c'est c'est en cela que
ça devient politique c'est-à-dire que ce
que j'ai ressenti moi j'étais pas le
seul à le ressentir et que derrière cet
appel il y a un record historique de
personnes qui ont participé parce que
derrière les émeutes ont scandalisé les
Français or les Français é on b ne
pouvant pas exprimer leur colère
vis-à-vis de la chianlie qui est
installée par certaines immigrations
tous les jours dans dans nos rues et
bien ils se sont emparés de cette
cagnotte comme d'un ils on on fait un
objet politique pour dire leur ralbol et
pour exprimer quelque chose il faut
entendre ce qui ce que dit cette
cagnotte pas seulement la critiquer donc
vous comprenez les émeutes alors ben non
justementel fois vous avez dit non pas
choqué vous j'ai non parce que c'est pas
choquant qu'il ait fait ça maintenant
c'est vrai que la somme qui est
astronomique qu à ce niveau-là c'est
vrai comme il dit S avaent été moins on
en aurait pas parlé ce que je regarde
c'est que c'est politisé et que c'est
surfé un peu sur la la souffrance par
exemple il faut pas oublier ce jeune
garçon qui a été tué quand même
évidemment la famille du policier aussi
évidemment les menaces de mort qu'il a
reçu évidemment la vie brisée évidemment
pas d'argent on sait ce que gagnent les
policiers après tout il avait le droit
de le faire attention il a continué à
toucher son salaire he le policier non
ça été interu moment au moment la canot
était lancé sal é non mais après il il a
remis géralin l' remis son salaire oui
mais ça au début on le savait pas au
début on savait pas alors oui je peux
vous donner une information si vous
voulez neutre sur la cagnote oui alors
je vous entends très mal monsieur oui je
peux vous donner une information neutre
si vous voulez sur la cagnote des 1
million et Jean mas si je me trompe vous
pourvez me corriger des 1630 11 an vous
quo non des
1636000 32000 d'accord on retire les
droits de donation et droit de mutation
60 % soit 938000 mais ce que je dis est
notutre c'est pas polémique je vous
corriger c'est faux et on ce que prend
la plateforme c'estàdire 68000 donc je
pense que la famille va toucher 625000 €
après impôt et taxes c'est faux je crois
vous avez pas très bien travailler votre
dossier parce qu'it la fiscalité des
donations elle se fait sur les dons de
plus de 500 € or nous avons à peu près
90 % des dons qui sont inférieurs à 500
€ donc non taxa non la totalité ils vont
toucher la totalité vous êtes sûr de
çael il vont payer quelques brottis sur
tous les dons qui sont supérieurs à 500
€ mais comm mais comme la quasi majorité
en totalité des dons est inférieure à
500 € sont ils sont pas taxables c'est
la loi fiscale vous avez 85000 donateurs
85000 donateurs mais pour pour un don
moyen de 20 ou 30 € donc ça sera pas
taxé et seul les les montants supérieurs
à 500 € parce que ce que votre
raisonnement e été vrai si on avait une
personne physique ou morale qui avait
donné cette somme donc là effectivement
ça aurait été le don d'une personne
identifiée et donc taxable à 60 % là
c'est pas le cas il y a 85000 personnes
avec un don moyen de 20 ou 30 € donc
taxer bah non toucher làdessus pensez
pas qu'il vont vous donner un petit truc
le le le d'abord le l'argent ne transite
pas par un tiers quand on ouvre une
cagnotte c'est au nom d'un bénéficiaire
don il faut fouriron est-ce que la
famille va peut-être vous donner quelque
chose mais non mais j'en veux pas moi
j'ai pas fait ça pour ça rien ou ah non
non il a pas le droit ou ah non non là
c'est absolument impossible il aura rien
il n a jamais été il n a jamais été
question ah oui enous table ouais pe a
jamais été question mais alors ça c'est
diffamatoire a je plaisante
diffamation j'espère que vous êtes bien
payé ici hein
Atta il a aucun problème j'ai aucun
problème avec ça oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe et la et la famille donc ne peut
pas utiliser ça pour l'action en justice
on est bien d'accord c'est uniquement
FAM non il faut bosser vos dossiers
uniquement pour les dépenses familiales
famille peut utiliser l'argent pour
payer ses avocats par exemple mais par
contre si il y a une condamnation
pécuniaire la famille ne peut pas
utiliser l'argent pour payer une
condamnation pécuniaire mais les frais
de justice entendu comme des frais
d'avocat là ils peuvent je les entendais
comme pénalité éventuelle donc on est
d'accord pour une fois bien enseigné
quand même vous êtes dit à mon avis bien
enseign attendez j'ai j'ai pas fait que
des études dans ma vie mais j'en ai fait
quelquesunes me permettant de répondre à
vos questions vous avez fait quoi ben
j'ai fait 12 années d'études après le
bac non quoi j'ai un doctorat en
sciences économiques je suis ancien
élève de Sciences Po Paris ancien élèv
de Lena vous êtes beaucoup ancien élèves
pardon non vous avez fait les deux Lena
et s Paris ouais vous avez arrêté vous
avez juste rentré et sorti ou non non
non j'ai fait 3 années d'études à
Science Po 2 années à Lena et 9 années
d'études pour mon doctorat pour passer
c'est la journée sur C news et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
C8 il m'at il
m' c'est pas à toi je répondre ça me ça
me permet de corriger les quelques
imprécisions et quelques ignorances et
de combler quelques lacunes sur ce
plateau vra
pas de non mais parlez pas de moi non
non non pas du tout jeai pas non j'ai eu
peur merci par contre lui il faut y
aller l'attaquer attaz problème avec ça
qui veut réagir moi sur la je suis un
peu choqué sur la cagnotte parce que ok
il est parti 4 mois en prison et je
rejoins ce que dit on aurait pu la la la
bloquer à 10000 € indemniser son salaire
aller jusqu'à 1 million6 bon il est
parti en prison peut-être il y en a qui
dis fallait pas qu'il y aille fallait
qu'il aille mais 1lion 6 la famille va
faire quoi avec les 1on question que je
vous pose moi cour il vont aller au
restaurant ils vont aller acheter une
maison ils vont acheter une voiture m
d'un petit il vont être content de
dépenser cet argent moralement ils vont
se dire on a pris 100lion 6 parce que
notre mari ou notre père ou notre oncle
tir à bout un gamin mais on va aller
quand même au mald avec
l'argent parce que vous croyz non mais
attendez vous viz dans quel monde vous
croyez que vous croyez que quand un flic
tire sur quelqu'un avec cette issue
tragique qu'on a connu vous croyz que le
flic il dort tranquille en disant [__]
j'ai fait j'ai j'ai explosé quelqu'un
j'ai tiré sur quelqu'un je suis
content un policier il faut savoir qu'en
France un policier qui sort son arme
dans de telles conditions sa carrière
est foutue il il la ressortira plus
jamais d'accord bon donc ça veut dire
que sa carrière dans la police est
terminée quel que soit l'issue hein sa
carrière dans la police est terminée et
donc il va falloir qu'il se
reconvertisse bah oui enfin écoutez le
petit enfin on va pas revenir voilà
c'est pas un petit parti trop t on est
bien d'ord alors il mérite pas cette il
mérite pas cela je dis pas ça je dis
mais ce qui tue en France c'est pas la
police c'est les refus d'obtempérer si
vous vous arrêtez vous risquez rien
voilà c'est tout il faut le dire et le
répéter quand la police vous intime lors
de vous arrêter il faut vous arrêter si
vous ne vous arrêtez pas vous mettez le
doigt dans un engrenage qui peut
effectivement être tragique c'est tout
c'est malheureux il y a des choses à pas
dire quand même c'est trop là c'estàdire
c'est trop non c'est la vérité attendez
mais vous dans quel pays dans quel pays
au monde quand quand quelqu'un fonce sur
un un barrage de police ne sort pas son
pour tirer
il barage il a failli attendez vous avez
vu les dernières vidéos vous avez vu les
der
VI il a fail écraser un cycliste des pit
et je te l'ai dit la semaine dernière il
avait écrasé ton ton gamin tuaurait dit
quoiou oui bonsoir Monsieur Messia moi
j'ai l'intime conviction que vous n'êtes
pas un escrot et que c'est pas un réseau
en non pas du tout je vous dis
effectivement que j'ai voté il a pris
chaud avec son P à mon
av non je trouve que vous avez fait
quand même passer Naël P à son âme pour
le délinquant qu'il n'est pas parce que
la seule sanction qu'il a même si il
était connu des services de police
c'était une sanction éducative en 2022
c'est bien ça problème non mais
justement je vous dis donc soutenir les
les policiers absolument oui il y a
aucun souci mais au dépend de la mort et
de se faire de cet argent de la mort de
ce petit non je suis pas d'accord et la
différence et si vous me permettez le
différence entre vous et Naël per son
âme c'est que vous vous avez un casi
judiciaire qui entâche a pas bien
évidemment bien si si si
siamème vous avez été aussi condamné AZ
aussi condamn pascrit révis alors vous
aussi vous
AZ ça sert à faire doctorat s économi
parce que ce que vous dites dépend des
condamnations ça dépend des catégories
de condamnation certaines ne sont
pas alors moi vous avez le droit en fait
vous avez le droit si vous de faire une
cagnote vous avez le droit moi je je ça
me gêne au niveau de l'éthique au niveau
de la moral c'estàd que je trouve qu'il
y a un truc un peu un peu obsène un peu
indécent parce que j'ai l'impression que
malgré vous même si vous avez
instrumentalisé ce fait d'hiver il y a
un truc un peu de Battle en gros combien
elle a eu la cagnotte de la mère de Naël
et combien il a eu la cagnotte du du du
policier et que donc du coup comme elle
elle a eu 490000 et que lui il a eu plus
d'un million en gros on se dit ah ouais
donc le pays est vraiment complètement
fracturé voilà et moi je suis du côté de
la police et je je je je soutiens ce
policier mais cette instrumentalisation
financière et pécunière moi elle me
déplais je la trouve Obs parce que je
trouve qu'elle divise encore plus que
avant le j'entends ce que vous me dites
mais je vais vous poser une question
est-ce que vous avez pas été choqué par
l'instrumentalisation de la mort de naë
par des grandes stars qui l'ont traité
immédiatement DEPS parti trop tô éé la
première à le dire sur le de la même
manière mais là l'argent c'est un truc
c'est un truc vraiment fort quand vous
claquez le montant quand même à la gule
de de de la maman de Naël je je je
comprends que ce soitès très violent
pour je je comprends bien mais moi vous
savez moi je excusez-moi mais personne
n'aurait pu prophétiser que la cagnote
allait faire autant avec autant de
donateurs vous savez quoi je vais même
vous dire quelque chose quand la cagnote
a été fermé j'ai reçu mais des tombreau
de messages de gens qui me disent mais
pourquoi elle a été fermé on voulait on
voulait participer j'ai même reçu des
des des personnes qui m'ont envoyé des
chèqus intitulés monsieur le policier ou
monsieurad f ambition Politi
monuramb
vousz en faisant ça vous frurez en tout
sur cette affaire là la seule ambition
que j'ai eu c'était d'aider une famille
que ça été mal pris par la famille d'en
face ça par contre ça pose un problème
si la PR c'est qu'ils ontorté ple contre
Mo il y a plein de gens qui sont moi je
suis pas avec la famille d'en face PE
importeelle est un pe ind Gérine je dire
un truc moi je comprends tout à fait que
il y a des choses qui peuvent qui
puissent choquer je suis moiême
choqué France voilà mais c'est pas pour
ça que j'iraai portter plainte pour
quelque chose qui me choque vous savez
en en la démocratie si on doit définir
une la démocratie c'est le droit à
choquer mais quand il y avait la la
cagotte quand il y avait la cagnotte du
boxeur détingé je sais pas si vous en
souvenez panté différ oui mais alors
pourquoi c'était différent la différent
parce que la cagnotte a été ouverte pour
payer justement la condamnation pécunite
interrompue donc il a pas le droit non
non non non non non non soyez précis la
cagnotte la cagnotte a été interrompue
parce que elle a été ouverte pour aider
ce boxeur à payer une condamnation
financière or ça c'est interdit par la
loi c'est illégal c'est sur cette base
juridique que la cagnote a été fermée la
cagnotte que moi j'ai lancé pour la
famille du policier elle n'a pas pu être
interdite par la loi parce qu'elle n'est
pas illégale et Dieu sait et Dieu sait
qu'il y a eu des saisines du
procureur et tout ce qui n'est pas
interdit par la loi est permis alors ça
peut choquer je comprends mais depuis
quand quand on est choqué on finit dans
un dans une audition
libre vous êtes d'accord si on fait une
cagnotte par exemple pour nordal lelanda
ou pour la maman de Jonathan
damra questionra
question ser mais je seraai extrêmement
choqué mais je pourquoi je je porterai
plein ça serait choquant si c'est pas
illégal dans une démocratie comme la
France tout ce qui n'est pas interdit
permis ça sera fait oui non à 81 % mer
81 % au revoir merci on se retrouve dans
un instant merci Jean Messia merci merci